and at what point were you like all
right I need to lose weight for my my
experience of high school was you know
like I said feeling out of place kind of
feeling bullied a little bit not really
knowing where do I fit in in the world
some of my friends who were successful
at the music that they played they got a
record deal and they were like okay
we're gonna go on tour if you want to
come with us and sell merch so on the
road it was like cigarettes alcohol fast
food gas station food you know no
working out like I'm just sitting at a
table all day selling T-shirts how do I
pass time there was a point where I was
19 and we were on a break from tour and
I'm just like I had a heart scare not
too long after that we went on our next
tour which was my last and on the road
there's a bunch of time to think and I
started like looking at everything
differently and I'm like these guys are
doing something that they love to do and
I'm just some extra guy that like is
helping them sell their t-shirts